alors on va distinguer trois catégories
de personnes la première ce sont plutôt
les enfants en bas âge voilà qui vont
dépendre des adultes pour s'hydrater et
qui n'ont pas spontanément demandé de
l'eau donc c'est les nourrissons
globalement jusqu'à deux ans et puis à
linverse on a les personnes âgées qui
sont plus fragiles pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que elles
n'ont pas la sensation de soif une
personne âgée elle ne va pas avoir soif
de la même manière que nous par
conséquent elle va se déshydrater sans
faire en de bruit regardez deuxième
chose à regarder l'heure d'assister
hydrate observé à vue d'oeil dirait une
figue séchée
personnage et faire passer sachant que
soif deuxième mécanisme elles n'ont pas
les mêmes mécanismes de régulation de la
température nous quand on a choqué ce
qui va se passer on va transpirer avec
l'âge les glandes qui nous permette de
transpirer sont un peu moins efficace
donc elles vont - réguler la température
pour ces deux raisons elles sont à
risque de formes graves lorsqu'il fait
très chaud les poken transfèrement quand
on est plus âgé nager exactement ce que
la transpiration ça fait évacuer la
chaleur dans mon transpire - on accumule
de la chaleur et si en plus de ça elle
n'a pas bu suffisamment et bien là il
risque le véritable coup de chaleur 3e
catégories de personnes celles qui vont
travailler dehors les ouvriers dans le
charmant sur fond des travaux qui ont
été exposés à la température à voir mes
coups de coeur qui vont faire le
ravalement cet été mais pour le nommer
pour de vrais ceux qui travaillent en
extérieur à risque de formes graves et
notamment la vue le véritable coup de
chaleur c'était une simple association
qui travaille dans nos mains des
conditions compliquées daniel vous vous
préparer comment
moi je vois beaucoup de travail tout le
temps donc voila mais c'est vrai que
vous avez raison par exemple ma maman
qui est très âgées ne demande jamais
c'est vraiment une surveillance tout le
temps et on lui donne régulièrement elle
voit partout et il n'aurait donc ça
c'est vrai que quand on est à côté d'une
personne âgée il faut vraiment y penser
on a toujours peur de la canicule comme
en 2003 est ce que c'est parce qu'il est
possible alors là le problème c'est
qu'on a peut-être manqué de soignant
notamment dans les rues l'ehpad et les
maisons de retraite c'est ce qui se
passe actuellement on n'a pas
suffisamment de soignants d'une façon
générale et dès lors que les résidents
nécessitent plus d'attention eh bien on
a besoin de plus de personnels sauf
qu'on se rend compte et bien que dans
les ehpad dans les mondes retraite est
né en manque de personnel par conséquent
la surveillance va être moins bonne
malgré les soignants ce qui veut donc
dire que peut-être on ne les verra pas
ce qui s'est passé en 2003 mais qu'on
pourra voir malheureusement de mauvaise
surprise et je vous rappelle qu'il
suffit d'une toute petite vague de
malades à l'hôpital pour engorger le
système donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit prudent dans l'avenir sur des
personnes plus jeunes filles bon bref on
beaucoup de support au soleil que c'est
pareil on a l'esprit du dimanche qui
tout d'un coup il fait beau on dire bah
tiens je vais mettre à courir j'ai
perdre du poids perdre du poids vous
allez français vous déshydrater et vous
risquez un véritable coup de chaleur je
vous rappelle celle de large et une
paire d oui comme ça c'est lorsque l'on
perd des 2 % d'eau donc c'est très peu
une déshydratation de vaud 2% c'est 20 %
de performances physiques en moins et
derniers chiffres lorsque vous
transpirez parce que vous faites un
exercice physique vous perdez entre un
demi litre et 2,5 litres de sueur parce
qu'ils vont version fait vraiment du
sport et sportive de renom mais si on
fait deux passes 4 heures sous le soleil
s'hydrater avant l'exercice choisi même
si vous n'avez pas soif et puis il faut
boire toutes les dix quinze minutes ça
on l'a vu pendant les matchs de foot
souvent ils font des pauses ferait
assurément oui mais pourquoi il s'arrête
et bien c'est ce qu'on doit faire
systématiquement toutes les 15 minutes
au moins un ou deux verres d'eau on
n'attend pas la verser de l'eau sur la
tête tout ça très bonne chose un oubli
que le fait de se mettre de l'eau ça
permet de rafraîchir la température
corporelle et ça nous évite de
transpirer encore plus ce qui va nous
faire déshydraté donc oui s'asperger
d'eau c'est valable aussi chez les
personnes âgées on peut les brumes is
est tout simplement la mère au japon
[Rires]
pour la façade c'est pour ma bible
qui recommande quand même de faire du
sport ou très tôt le matin ou tard le
soir mais pas dans la journée plus tôt à
l'intérieur c'est renteria journée pour
l'heure il faut être là au sauf si on a
l'habitude des cons aspects relatifs à
geri écossais qu'on le fait
régulièrement mais c'est pas le moment
de se dire tiens je met assez ça va
aller du parti
attendait la fin de l'après midi très
tôt le matin c'est bien ou l esi
progressivement mais surtout fera
vraiment vous hydrater d'autant plus que
la sensation de soif lorsque vous faites
du sport c'est un signal tardif vous
risquez d'en blesser bêtement tard
lorsque la soif est déjà apparu c'est
parfois trop tard donc il faut boire
sans avoir soif ou alors surveiller ses
urines
c'est ce que vous étés
réunir ce que c'est que ça oui c'est
quoi les symptômes du coup de chaleur
alors faut distinguer plusieurs choses
quand on parle de coup de chaleur le
coup de chaleur c'est lorsque vous êtes
exposé dehors à une forte température
vous ne buvez pas ça en fait de
l'activité physique voilà les beaucoup
transpiré par conséquent votre
température corporelle qui doit rester
normalement à 37 degrés et bien
lorsqu'il fait chaud vous aller
transpirer pour réguler cette
température si vous n'avez plus d'eau
dans le corps eh bien vous ne pouvez
plus réguler la température la
température corporelle va monter vous
arrivez à 38 39 40 et ça c'est le
véritable coup de chaleur on a de la
fièvre ont fait un véritable malaise on
atterrit aux urgences si on finit en
réanimation on peut mourir d'un
véritable coup de chaleur et dernière
chose parfois je vois des patients qui
vont s'exposer au soleil la veille et le
lendemain me disent oh c'est bizarre
j'ai de la fièvre j'ai mal au ventre sur
peut-être que j'ai été trop exposé au
soleil non le coup de soleil le coup de
chaleur c'est immédiat le lendemain si
vous avez des symptômes c'est que vous
avez autre chose la gastro la bronchite
le coc vite peu importe tous les
symptômes que vous avez à distance d'une
exposition au soleil n'a strictement
rien à voir avec le soleil oui certains
conseils de manger le moins possible
quand il est chaud est assez bonne idée
vous mangez normalement faut manger
normalement il n'y a pas de raison de
restreindre son alimentation vous avez
besoin d'un apport calorique régulier si
votre métabolisme c'est d'abord entre
1500 et 2000 kcal si vous mangez mille
kcal et bien vous allez en déficit de
calories que vous allez peut-être perdre
un peu de poids mais ça n'a pas
d'intérêt sur l'hydratation vous on
s'alimente malgré tout on s'hydrate
aussi avec l'alimentation donc les
fruits et les légumes sont une bonne
source d'hydratation donc si vous
décidez de plus rien manger bah c'est
pas l'idée du siècle oui timide il vaut
mieux boire froid ou plutôt comme dans
le désert chaud a alors ça c'est vrai
que ça c'est une bonne question avec
dans le désert au beau chaud alors déjà
il faut éviter de boire très froid
langue là c'est moi je voyais froid bien
l'eau glaciale et des conseillers pour
deux raisons une autre la première c'est
que lorsque vous buvez très très froid
au niveau de température corporelle va
pas tellement bougé vous n'allez pas
vous rafraîchir outre mesure c'est
souvent douloureux de boire très froid
et en plus de ça vous allez en quelque
sorte tromper votre corps et va se dire
ouh là là il fait très froid à
l'intérieur il va falloir produire de
l'énergie et essayer de transpirer
encore plus donc c'est contre-productif
de boire très froid puis deuxième chose
lorsque vous buvez de l'eau glacée
s'entraînent une vaso constriction des
vaisseaux sanguins qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est à dire que le flux sanguin et
un peu moins présents notamment au
niveau du tube digestif heitz a ralenti
la digestion et ça donne mal au ventre
c'est pour ça notamment que les enfants
quand il mange une glace très froide une
lisa j'ai mal au ventre merci lié au
fait que l'estomac un peu moins de 100
et par conséquent il ne faut pas boire
très froid pour s'hydrater
justement pour les enfants et même les
adultes mais en cas d'insolation dorée à
la relation est à vous avez dit des
nausées on peut vomir et qu'est ce qu'on
fait on emmène tout c'est aux urgences
oui mais on peut quand même attendre à
l'horizon on retire l'enfant de
l'exposition à la chaleur on l'idrac
c'est à dire qu'on a lancé de l'eau pour
refroidir un petit peu on le fait bois
on se laisse quelques minutes si on se
rend compte qu'au bout de quelques
minutes l'enfant retrouve ses esprits il
est cohérent il n'est pas confus mais
dans ces cas là il n'y a pas lieu
d'aller à l'hôpital en revanche si la
température corporelle commence à monter
vous êtes au delà de 38 degrés cela il
faut d'urgence faut pas chercher
moi je suis sur un texto mais
franchement incroyable de caveman des
équipes franchement ça vous concerne
dernier mot inquiet pour le coup de
chaleur mais daniel moss nemande telles
qu'elles sont on
[Rires]
fait savoir
vous en voyez ça
oui mais le problème de la canicule
c'est la nuit les températures baissent
où va la nuit donc on achète des
ventilateurs qui s'arrache en ce moment
mais certains disent qu'en fait c'est
trompeur parce que ça habitue le corps à
une fausse température est ce que c'est
vrai ou est-ce que vous conseiller le
ventilateur qu'on branche comme ça lors
honnêtement le ventilateur c'est du
confort donc on peut pas dire aux gens
qui souhaitent acheter un ventilateur
n'en achetez pas ça va tromper votre
corps c'est une mesure alternative à la
climatisation parce que tout le monde ne
peut pas avoir la clim et c'est pas
forcément bon pour la planète donc le
ventilateur n'est pas une mauvaise idée
c'est vous permet de dormir de façon
plus confortable puisque je vous
rappelle que pour bien dormir il faut
que la température soit un peu plus
basse c'est pour ça notamment que
lorsqu'il fait très chaud on a du mal à
dormir les fortes températures entraîne
des troubles du sommeil et par
conséquent on est moins bien reposé donc
pourquoi pas le ventilateur chaleur de
positionner les cinq conseils de jimmy
face à la canicule je vais demander à
daniel de sa prochaine
en attendre les 5 conseils note jimmy
donc on l'a dit à mes conseils savoir
quelle quantité d'eau examen et celui de
regarder ses urines à le test du verre
qu'on peuvent tous faire à la maison
c'était vraiment des jurys dans la vase
pas vraiment mais bon
en gros c'est
[Applaudissements]
sécurité gilles verdez
la
bélarusse darya nature whisky cas cela
dit
[Applaudissements]
une petite odeur de lyon fou
[Rires]
c'est dingue est
possible c'est moi pas
cessé
boussion du limousin
[Rires]
soulageant vidéo wesh sadate
agnel merci à tous d'avoir tué
l'exercice
du mit ses quatre revers
parce que souvent on me demande mais
quelle quantité d'eau il faut boire par
jour mais exaltant souvent un lead 5,2
litres mais ce chiffre est plutôt faux
ou plutôt vrai ça dépend comment on voit
les choses en tout cas d'une façon très
générale on sait que l'hydratation
dépend de plusieurs femmes paramètres
votre poids corporel plus on est grand
et gros et puis il faut boire de
l'activité physique et puis de la
température qui fait à l'extérieur
regardez vos urines vous serez
exactement comment vous est hydratée
normalement les urines ressemble à saray
sont plutôt jaune pâle elles n'ont pas
d'odeur elles sont presque transparente
ça veut dire que votre vitre
correctement les déchets et qu'elles
sont très peu concentré et ça c'est bien
ça donc ça s'est bien passé par sont
claires c'est mieux c'est et ça c'est
valable chez tout le monde
je suis à deux doigts de faire pipi dans
un arrêt rendu
ici
dans la bouteille ça
et pour son gré plus ça veut dire que
votre rat doit travailler pour justement
éliminer les déchets et par conséquence
à celle mesurée de quelqu'un qui est
déshydratée générale pour savoir si vous
êtes bien hydraté bien vous regardez
votre travail de plus il est transparent
et plus les reins fonctionnent
correctement et moi vous avez besoin de
boire d'eau puisque les indépendances
vous êtes bien hydraté je reste ou
simple jeanneret tellement faire pipi
et chez les enfants parfois qu'il porte
la couche on se demande mais comment
savoir si le dernier daté et bien on
regarde le voir ou de l'accouchement si
jamais sur deux ou trois change on se
rend compte que la couche elle un peu
vide merci que l'enfant n'a pas fait
suffisamment et donc qu'il ne boit pas
suffisamment dans ces cas là on les
hydrates si la maman allaite elle peut
donner le sein s'il prend des solutés de
réhydratation on peut ordonner ont fait
boire de l'eau on ne donne pas de
boissons gazeuses sucrées elles ne sont
pas du tout adaptés à une dégradation ni
d'alcool l'alcool c'est vraiment la
mauvaise ici
c'est
très important si vous nous regardez
regardez bien d'autres aides publiques
comme ça attention car tout cas comme ça
attention après intel quand même
l'assassinât non ça va c'est magnifique
à bas la lie à alert est là s'est tout
de suite bien sûr ça
y aller voir un mec là vie non pas les
voir il
faut augmenter vos apports en eau est
normal de s'éclaircir petit à petit si
malgré tout il reste telle qu'elle est
vraiment avec claudette qui a un
problème au niveau des essais nucléaires
colère de classe et très graves si elles
sont beaucoup mieux même si ses rétros
n'y a pas tellement de scientifiques
vinolo ça va non alors ça veut juste
dire que vous rajoutez limina volaille
te ment
on a des patients qui sont poteau malawi
ces grèves ou 6 litres d'eau par jour
quand on va perturber le fonctionnement
du métabolisme le sodium c'est à dire le
sel va être beaucoup trop bas et je vous
rappelle que ce qui avait tué notamment
les personnes âgées durant la canicule
c'est pas le fait simplement de manquer
d'eau c'est qu'on les hait hydrate et
que avec de l'eau sans apporter de sel à
mes seins souhaite avoir une bonne
hydratation et maintenir une tension
petit faute de l'eau et un but said
apports en sel sa critique et hypnotique
donc on n'hésite pas on ne fait pas de
régime sans sel strict du robinet ne
donnant pas alors le elles sont pas
assez salée en fait le seul si on boit
massivement juste de l'eau eh bien on va
avoir tendance à faire baisser le taux
de sodium et par conséquent les
personnages et les meufs moins bien le
tolérer enfin attention sodium est la
plus le sodium exactement le rôle de
sonja hahn avec le renault dacia n'a pas
vu du ciel
le nitrate noircies c'est mon seul
connaît la formule du nitrate de
potassium c'est pas me traynard y est tu
t'arrêtes de tara tard cinquième
année bien que ces cartes potassium way
back c'est non bbc ce point faire valoir
dont 10 me je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure deuxième conseil dont premier
conseil savoir quelle quantité de bois
deuxième conseil ne surtout pas boire
très froid il a dit tout à l'heure voire
très froid ça va berne et le corps le
corps va dire où il fait froid
et en fait non boire de l'eau à
température ambiante ou de l'eau très
chaude oui dany même temps qu'il fait
très chaud très chaud très chaud très
chaud des bédouins aller vers un point
très chaud et c'est puisque lorsque vous
buvez très chaud vous allez en quelque
sorte avant une espèce de coup de
chaleur et par conséquent vous aller
transpirer assez rapidement et ça fait
baisser votre température corporelle no
- tu es très chaud permet de façon très
ponctuelle de se rafraîchir évidemment
il fait ce concours c'est ensuite avec
de l'eau à température ambiante c'est
parfait c'est pour ça qu'ils font ça
dans le désert notamment je rigole c'est
pas du tout pour vous dis mais c'est que
giono soir aussi réitéré hier son
travail que moi qui s'appelle tarik et
j'ai des problèmes de moucherons chez
moi à rager déboucheront voilà qui fait
ça m'énerve qu'ils m'envoient demain 12h
30 il nie clara ca tous les moucherons
[Rires]
voilà donc apparemment à 12h30 les
moucherons
quatrième conseil comme ça ne pas boire
d'alcool non parce que c'est vrai que on
installe mi-mars fois un tient à voir
des gens sur les terrasses beau il fait
chaud c'est totalement quand on doit 12
bières fraîches comme un jardin c'est
vraiment pas c'est vraiment pas du tout
adapté une bonne hydratation au
contraire ça va vous déshydrater pour
deux raisons la première c'est que pour
éliminer l'alcool que vous avez consommé
et bien vous allez utiliser de l'eau
donc vous allez utiliser des ressources
dont votre corps a besoin et puis
deuxième chose l'alcool va perturber le
fonctionnement d'une hormone qu'on
appelle leur mode antidiurétique cette
hormone elle vous empêche notamment de
faire si si c'est pour ça que la nuit on
ne se lève pas pour les rues uriner
puisqu'on à cette hormone qui est bien
concentré l'alcool elle lève cette
hormone est par conséquent vous allez
beaucoup plus sur pipi et donc vous
allez vous hydratez ne buvait pas
d'alcool lorsqu'il fait très chaud c'est
la meilleure façon d'être déshydraté ou
de faire mal et on fait beaucoup publie
sans rigoler non sinon jamais
l'allemagne enfin me rendais pas compte
de ce
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'a fait aussi sa des zetas a
déshydraté non alors le café c'est
légèrement bioéthique comme le thé ça
fait un tout petit peu uriner en
revanche toutes les études montrent que
la consommation de café 2 à 3 verres par
jour même parfois un peu plus est
bénéfique pour la santé cardiovasculaire
un petit café c'est bon pour la santé et
même ceux de voix qui a coiffé une
sommation excessive de café qui aura à
boire 5 6 à 7 par jour il n'y a pas
d'effets secondaires sont voilà si tu
vois trop de café battus voire des
problèmes de coeur et bien ça c'est
plutôt faux il n'y a pas d'effets
secondaires fabrice lucas café mais chez
certaines personnes ça peut accélérer un
tout petit peu le coeur donc on vous
tiens je me sens un peu énervé c'est
l'effet de la caféine mais sur le long
terme le café c'est bénéfique et encore
une fois lorsqu'on parle de café on dire
ouh là là après 16h 17h faut pas boire
chacun une sensibilité bien sûr 4 et
même à 22h moubarak exactement non mais
certains écrits et dormir très bien et
d'autres vont prendre un café à 15 16
heures et là c'est terminé vont très mal
dormi direction donc le café c'est bon
pour la santé ah oui mais bon ça est-ce
que l'eau de coco
hydratant et
pas pourquoi pas c'est vrai que quand on
leur ait aussi
ce cas là et pourquoi pas c'est plein de
minéraux
si jamais vous n'aimez pas l'eau et ça
arrive à beaucoup de personnes qui n'ont
mais j'aime pas boire de l'eau si vous
préférez de l'autre coco il n'y a pas de
problème évitez les boissons trop
sucrées l'autre coco s'est pas tu
l'impression et voilà
la liqueur de mandela
demande sodas light c'est vraiment des
conseillers pour plusieurs raisons ou
alors parce que ça vous hydrate pas
c'est bon mais sion alors moi moi je
prends toujours une bouteille d'eau et
un soda light ça alors le soda là il
faut pas oublier qu'il ya des
édulcorants de dans des faux sucre c'est
faux sucre chez soi rien à voir ce qui
donne le goût sucré les faux sucre le
saccharose l'acésulfame k ce sont des
édulcorants c'est ce qui donne le goût
sucré alors tout d'abord vous avez pas
perdre de poids que ces boissons
édulcorants parce que jamais personne a
perdu du poids avec samian pas me
pardonneront pas vous en prendre pas
mais vous allez rester en afrique et au
sucre il est gonflé ce que
systématiquement dit comme c'est pas
sucré je continue de boire hasard et en
plus ça contient des édulcorants et les
études démontrent que ces édulcorants
perturbent le fonctionnement de notre
flore intestinale avec en fait ces
boissons elle n'apporte strictement rien
buvez de l'eau s'est largement à
messiaen quittant petit
côté coup de sifflet de l'eau pas
d'alcool
vérité dans ce cas là je m'occupe daniel
épi
mais c'est vrai quitte à passer dès
cette date en soit là
et c'est bien peu qu'on trouve un juste
milieu entre croire que ces boissons
sont totalement inoffensives et croire
qu'elles vont vous donner super malin et
qu'une force que la vérité entre les
deux dates en juillet un lobby énorme
pour nous faire comprendre par les
boissons elles sont adaptées vous
rappelle que ces boissons elles sont
aussi acide lorsqu elles contiennent du
sucre ou sans sucre et ça donne des
caries aux enfants presse à ataq l'émail
donc ces boissons elle favorise les
caries maintenant je vous donne
l'information vous savez qu'elles sont
pas faites pour votre santé libre à vous
de les consommer d'alcool à vous fans
allez on fait ça chez
vous buvez quoi votre yacht au niveau
des boissons la boisson ça qu'est-ce que
vous l'âme
et donc ne pas pâlir bois
divers
5e merci jimmy juste non mais c'est vrai
qu'on ne rigole mais voilà sinon c'est
important derniers conseils vous dit
faut manger des fruits et légumes riches
en deçà il a dit tout à l'heure ça c'est
important
parce que certains n'aiment pas boire de
l'eau on l'a dit les personnages et l on
a beau les forces et vont nous dire non
donc
et on oublie que les fruits et les
légumes contiennent de l'eau donc si
jamais vous consommez des pastèques des
melons honda tomates des concombres de
l'oranje du pamplemousse et bien le
contiennent plus de 90 % de leur poids
en eau donc une façon de s'hydrater ceux
ci passait par de l'alimentation
halal à l'isolément
qui fait tomber mon stylo ou progrès
comme un légume ces concombres et alors
que c'est un fou
mais on rigole en ce moment je vois de
plus en plus d'infections urinaires les
cystites ça durant cette période de
l'année lorsqu'il fut rappelle la
chanson de michael jackson si
ce mandat qui se touchent et la tournée
des idoles bien sûr
des années
et donc oui et donc quand on boit moins
d'eau mais plus à risque de faire des
halles infections urinaires et joie de
plus en plus de femmes en ce moment à
consulter pour juger les infections
urinaires donc il faut boire
correctement et on sait aussi que
l'absence d'hydratation favorise la
formation des calculs au niveau des
reins la police a fait très mal beaucoup
plus réparer l'année lorsqu'il fait très
chaud le boire des traitements si la
prévention est donc bu régulièrement
génie de seuil et des vases il est aussi